-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
It's time to play "Jinx"!
-Ohh!
-♪ J-J-J-Jinx, J-J-J-Jinx ♪
-Well, our first team is this.
She stars
in the new limited series
"The Thing About Pam,"
which premieres tomorrow
at 10:00 p.m. on NBC.
And he is the host
of "The Tonight Show."
It's Renee Zellweger
and Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
And their opponents.
He's the emcee of
the legendary Roots crew.
-Wow!
-And his show,
"David Byrne's American Utopia,"
is on Broadway now.
It's Tariq Trotter
and David Byrne!
-Oh, my goodness!
That is exactly right!
Wow. Alright.
-Well, well, well!
The rules of this game
are fairly simple.
I will read your team
a category.
-Uh-huh.
-And then you will then count
to three and both name something
in that category
at the same time.
-Mm-hmm.
-If you say the same thing,
you get a Jinx.
-That's good.
-Make sense?
-Yeah.
-Any questions?
We want to have --
-Okay. Great.
Renee and Jimmy
-Yeah --
-You're up first.
Did you have a question?
-Well, yeah,
I was just wondering --
-Okay. You guys are up first.
To help you link your minds,
would you please
put your pinkies together,
a la pinky swear?
May I have the category please?
-[ Air whooshes ]
-We got this, bud. We got this.
-Alright. Ready?
-Well, that was
amazing technology.
-That's a pneumatic tube.
-Yeah, you could have
just had a card up there.
-No, no, no.
But this is a tube.
-I understand.
-Because it's called "Jinx."
-Yep.
-So, okay, ready?
-Yes. We got this.
-Put your minds together.
The category is...
something green.
Whenever you're ready.
-Something green.
Okay. Ready?
Three, two, one.
-Grass!
-Shamrock!
Ohh!
-[ Buzzer ]
-Grass, of course. Of course.
-You get another chance.
-We have another chance?
Something green. And can we
say the same word again or no?
-No.
-Change it.
Okay. We'll change it up.
Something green.
Something --
-Just keep saying the same word.
Eventually you'll get --
-I know. Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, thank you, David.
Thanks for the help.
Something green. Wait, wait.
-Ready?
-Wait. No, I'm not ready.
Because I'm thinking so --
of something green.
I can't even -- Alright.
Wait.
I can't give hints or anything.
This is tough. Something --
-This isn't looking good.
-Alright. Alright. I could --
Maybe I got this. Ready?
Are we gonna lose?
-I think so.
-Okay. Here we go.
Ready? Come on. Ready?
One, two, three.
-Spinach! Ohh!
-Pea soup!
-Pea soup?!
[ Laughter ]
-Pea soup?
-What?
Why can't I say pea soup?
-When is the last time
you had pea soup?
-I don't know.
I haven't had it -- Alright.
-Pea green soup.
-Green.
-You want a hint?
-Wait. Ready for green.
Here we go. We got this.
Ready? Something green.
I know what it is. Ready?
[ Clears throat ] Mmm...
-Come on, come on.
-One, two, three.
Money!
-[ Shouts indistinctly ]
Ohh!
[ Buzzer ]
-See, here's --
here's what you did, Jimmy.
-What?
-You dropped that "Mm, mm, mm."
-Yes.
-"Mm, mm, mm."
-You heard me drop that?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I still didn't get it.
It didn't work.
-It didn't work for you.
-You know what I kept --
You know why?
Here's why it didn't work.
Because I kept thinking in my
head "Kermit" the whole time.
-Yeah, why didn't you say
Kermit then?
-Because I didn't think
you would say Kermit.
-Aww.
-I know. Yeah.
-David and Tariq, you're up.
It's time to meld your minds.
So please pinky swear.
May I have the category?
-Oh, on the -- on this pillow.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's hard to get out of there.
Alright. Ready?
The category is...
a U.S. coin.
-Mm.
-U.S. coin.
-Okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
-Easy. One, two, three.
-Quarter!
-What in the --
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-You got confetti?
-Yeah.
-For quarter?
-For quarter. Wow!
-That's...
-My goodness!
-It rains on us.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Quarter.
-"Mm, mm, mm."
-I mean, ours was very generic.
Anything green.
Yeah. You both went,
"Qu-qu-qu..."
-Penny, nickel, dime, quarter.
-Oh, get out of here.
-Qua-nickel. Qua-nickel.
-You guys ready?
Renee and Jimmy, are you ready?
-Yes, we are ready.
-May I have the category,
please?
-Come on. We got this.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Last name of a famous Tom.
Whenever you're ready.
-One, two, three.
-Cruise!
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow!
-Yes!
-Show me the money.
-Okay.
-Which was something green,
as well.
[ Overlapping dialogue ]
-It's a tie game.
-David and Tariq. 3-3.
Back to you.
May I have the category?
-Okay.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So much pressure.
That's a lot of pressure.
-Okay. Okay.
-It's -- The pinky
is what gets you --
-Yeah, yeah.
-There's a little communication
going on there.
-Okay. This is
something people collect.
Something people collect.
-Okay. Hm.
Come on, David.
-Okay. I'm ready.
You want me to count?
-Count. Go.
-Three, two, one.
-Antiques.
-Stamps.
-Ooh!
-Ooh.
-I was thinking stamps.
I was thinking stamps.
-You have another chance.
-I said, "No.
David's gonna go antiques."
-You have another chance.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Whenever you're ready.
-Three, two, one.
-Cars.
-Coins.
-Ohh!
-No, no, no, no. Stop.
Absolute-- No. Stop.
-No. Wait. No, no, no.
You said cars.
-Everybody stop.
The Roots are rooting for you.
-I said, "Coi-ars."
-You said, "Coi-ars."
-I said, "Cars."
[ Laughter ]
-He said, "Coi-ars."
-Tariq now lives
in such rarified air.
-It's not a word.
He said, "Coi-ars."
And then the band
and confetti and everything.
No. Absolutely not.
-Okay, okay.
-"Coi-arns."
-They'll allow it.
They'll allow it.
-Alright. So something
that people collect.
Unfortunately, "coi-rns"
is not an answer.
-"Corns"?
-Alright. Okay.
-So we get one more?
We get one more chance?
-You get one more chance.
-Okay, okay, okay.
[ Overlapping dialogue ]
-"Kerns" is used.
-You said "kernels"?
-Okay, okay.
Ready?
-Give me a second.
Give me a second. Okay.
Things people collect.
-Mm-hmm.
-Alright.
Three, two, one.
Art.
-[ Exhales sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-You didn't answer.
-Yes, I did.
-What did you say?
-Art.
-You did not. You did not.
-Yes, I did.
-You didn't say --
Nothing came out of his mouth.
-It was faint. It was a faint...
[ Rasta horn blares ]
It was a lighthearted...
-Judges.
-Nothing came out of his mouth.
He was like -- He exhaled.
-Alright. Still a tie game.
[ Buzzer ]
Still a tie game.
-Okay, okay.
-You can't do that.
-Be that way. Be that way.
[ Rasta horn blares ]
-Oh, whoa! You know
what that sound means.
-What?
-It's time for the final round.
-Okay.
-That was fast.
-This is it.
-The first team to get Jinx
gets 10,000 points.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Renee and Jimmy,
you're up first. Ready?
-No pressure.
-May I have the category?
-We got this. It's easy.
-Remember. It goes like this.
You get one, you don't get it,
they get a chance to steal.
It goes back and forth
until somebody gets it.
-Here we go.
We'll get this right here.
-Pick a number
between one and one million.
-That's ridiculous.
-I'm teasing. That's a joke.
Okay, good. Thank you.
-I'm a professional.
-"Coi-ern."
-Name a kern.
[ Laughter ]
Are you ready?
-Yes.
-A Batman villain.
A Batman villain.
This is for 10,000 points.
-Ready?
-Yeah!
-One, two, three.
-Ridd--
-Joker! Oh!
[ Buzzer ]
-Why would I --
Why would I say that?
I can't believe I said Riddler.
Why would I --
-You said "Riddler"?
-Well, I barely -- I said --
I said "Rid-joker."
-Coi-ern?
-Yeah. I said "corn" basically.
-Okay. Ready?
Don't say what they said.
Whenever you guys are ready.
-One, two, three.
-The Joker.
-Joker.
[ Bell dinging ]
-Come on, baby.
-Unbelievable.
That is so rigged.
I got to go back and review
all of this.
My thanks to Renee Zellweger,
my partner.
David Byrne and Tariq Trotter
are the champs.
Steve Higgins. We're talking to
Renee and David after the break.
Stick around.
More "Tonight Show."